mais là messieurs bonjour bienvenue à
tam tam
une autre édition consacrée au mondial
vous savez qu'on a traversé déjà la
première phase le 1er tour dans sa phase
préliminaire vous avez peut-être des
équipes que vous surveillez vous êtes
peut-être content aux déçus en tout cas
le panel d'experts et d'amateurs du
ballon rond de rci a aussi son regard
très avisé sur sur le sujet alors sans
plus tarder je vous les présente tout de
suite on a en face de moi palma martinez
des sections françaises espagnoles
merci bonjour pas l'om on a israel ou
dassine qui est le nouveau venu dans
l'équipe
il fait partie de la section française
de rci c'est le fier représentant de
l'afrique dans ce panel a guère que vous
connaissez déjà qui en portugais
d'origine qui s'intéressent au football
sic est le fondateur de luz au presse
vous pouvez définir pour quelle équipe
son coeur balance
et puis bon joueur bon jour et robert
frosi qu'on ne présente plus notre
expert multisports à radio canada et qui
lui l homme neutre de la situation parce
que mais là si l'italie on va y aller
tout de suite bon les amis
est-ce que et à quelque chose qui vous a
surpris
dans cette coupe du monde depuis qu'elle
a commencé robert on commence par vaux
l'homme neutre est ce que une grosse
surprise
évidemment parce que
d'habitude de l'adage disait que à la
fin ce sont les allemands qui gagnent et
bien là on devra mettre aux oubliettes
cet adage qui a tenu pendant des
décennies et non là cette fois ci c'est
encore la malédiction des champions du
monde en titre c'est en cinq coupes du
monde les les tenants du titre ne passe
pas le premier tour
peut-être une allemagne désorganisés
trop confiante certains m'ont confié
qu'ils avaient pas une ambiance géniale
dans le vestiaire allemand peut-être des
guerres de génération peut-être des
guerres d'ego on l'avait vécu avec la
france en 2010 en afrique du sud où il y
avait eu cette fameuse grève où on
voulait pas descendre de l'autobus
peut-être que ça ressemble un petit peu
à ça et ça s'est vu sur le terrain parce
que parce qu'eux mêmes ils ont pas du
tout été les allemands réaliste qu'on
connaît contre les coréens leur dernier
match et ça a été un cauchemar
ouais il la deuxième surprise c'est
l'absence des pays africains au deuxième
tour on y reviendra parce que je sais
d'eygalières était la dernière équipe
qui pouvait sauver le continent absolue
elle ne l'a pas fait en fait si elle l'a
fait mais elle s'est fait rattraper par
les règlements on arrive effectivement
dans un instant parlement et vous moi ma
soeur je vais prêcher pour ma paroisse
pour ma paroisse j'étais surprise elle
de la dernière performance de l'équipe
mexicaine
je n'ai pas compris qu est ce qui s'est
passé ils avaient très bien fait équipe
avec lui je brise enfin de mauvaise
surprise mauvaise surprise je pensais
qu'ils allaient être plus forts devant
la suède
et puis non parce qu'il y avait des
files l'équipe avait été très forte à
l'allemagne et même avec l'accord est il
y avait montré ses couleurs
mais face à la suède elle était
complètement défaite donc que j'étais
vraiment surprise j'ai avec comme espoir
que le
la force de l'équipe soit la profondeur
de l'équipe se voit même contre la suède
qui avait éliminé l'italie pour ne pas
se rendre au championnat donc j'étais un
peu surprise voilà mais elle a appris
des bouts de coréens maintenant elle va
d'autres sont en rien son équipe qu'à
ses moeurs bientôt une surprise agréable
désagréable ben c'est sûr que robert a
déjà parlé l'allemagne passe à côté
ce que j'ai trouvé très intéressant
c'est la résistance des morts du maroc
de l'aidant dans le groupe 2b contre le
portugal champion d'europe l'espagne qui
était l'ancien champion de rang ils ont
très bien fait il aurait pu passer aux
huitièmes de finale et c'était c'était
très beau à voir a marqué mon coeur a eu
les yeux tels que le journaliste faisait
titre on voit plus remarquée que
l'adversaire était coriace il autre
chose que j'aime bien c'est au niveau
général
je pense que le score était de haut
niveau même s'il ya eu panama qui avait
pris six buts de l'angleterre
je pense c'était un peu trop 2 parce que
au niveau du soccer je pense que c'était
un peu plus équilibré que les six buts
c'est de cela que j'ai pu remarquer
c'est très clair alors ismaël
le maroc est sorti par la grande porte
mais mais encore qu'est ce qui vous
frappe est sortie par la grande porte
mais disons le honorablement une équipe
quand même que ces battues qui a montré
un niveau assez acceptable des puits qui
qui par manque de chance aussi et est
éliminé mais il ya quelque chose moi qui
m'a surpris mais qui m'a peut-être plus
estomaqué c'est le match france danemark
alors seul
c'était incroyable j'ai vraiment aucun
niveau 2 mondial ici c'était
plate à mourir c'était vraiment ça
c'était le match destruction bas en
coupe du monde on veut plus on est plus
d'ailleurs les deux équipes ont été
sifflés par les gradins à la fin du
match donc qui s'est joué mardi dernier
donc ça a été quand même pas très
glorieux pour ces deux équipes qui se
retrouvent néanmoins en huitièmes c'est
pour ça peut-être aussi leur n'avait pas
beaucoup d'enjeu ceci expliquant cela
oui quoi bien voulu réagir à ce match
soporifique c'était un support un ding
ding une coupe du monde
d'ailleurs les journalistes feraient un
journaliste français a eu cette
trouvaille magnifique
il a titré voyage au bout de l'ennui
et et ça résume vraiment c'est ça résume
vraiment ce n'est pas normal qu'à un
niveau de compétition comme celui là on
donne un bon spectacle à des gens qui se
sont déplacés à des supporters qui
croient dans les deux équipes est de
livrer et de livrer quelque chose
d'épouvantable c'est pas digne de
grandes nations de football
on peut en tout cas moi je trouve que
c'est peut-être que
quelqu'un va intervenir dans ce dossier
là et projet j'aimerais après qu'on
revienne sur le maroc parce que le maroc
n'a été aussi pas juste a été une
victime a été entre autres une victime
de l'arbitrage vidéo et moi j'ai
beaucoup à redire là dessus parce que ça
fait ça fait ça aussi c'est
insupportable pas fourni reviendra alors
au niveau de la compétition parce que
total en orbite au haras glisser un
petit mot est ce que vous trouvez que le
niveau de compétition
de façon générale est assez relevé assez
satisfaisant qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
il est très bon on vraiment le niveau ne
sais pas pour mes collègues mais moi
j'ai trouvé que ça commence en tout cas
très bien et ce après ça présage de très
bons combats sur le terrain non moi je
pense que c'était ça c'est très bon plus
premier tour lambert est un formidable
formidable à part ce que j'ai à dire sur
france danemark mais mais formidable
parce que et norberto on avait parlé à
la dernière émission de dures du
resserrement en fait un
le lait les joueurs voyagent de plus en
plus sont dans des grandes compétitions
dans des grands championnats et on sent
on le sent à tous les niveaux on n'a pas
encore parlé de peut-être deux belles
surprises qu'on attendait un petit peu
moi je disais même beaucoup les belges
et les croates ce sont ceux qui vont le
plus impressionné depuis le début de la
compétition qui joue un football total
les belges c'est pas un hasard là encore
sur l'équipe le onze je pense qu'il y en
a dix qui jouent en angleterre
donc ça veut dire qu'on a été s'inspirer
du on a ramené en fait avec avec soin ce
niveau de jeu et on le sent même les
coréens qui on les connaissait dans les
coupes du monde mais même eux sont
vraiment surprenants
les japonais aussi donc ça veut dire que
mondialement le soccer et le niveau de
sa cure se se resserre moi j'ai plus une
question comme comme un talent mais ça
va ceux qui connaissent mieux que moi le
juge ait l'impression que le niveau pas
le niveau mais un type de jeu un genre
de jeu qui vient d'aider l'europe une
autre genre qui vient de l'amérique du
sud ou encore de la cie mais est ce que
les niveaux peuvent être mis au même
même titre que ça s'homogénéise qualité
du jeu oui je pense que le
le jeu va être toujours différent parce
qu'on peut pas comparer le jeu de
l'angleterre qui joue le ballon avec le
mexique le brésil au pied c'est
différent mais c'est sûr que les joueurs
qui vont jouer ceux de l'amérique du sud
qui vont jouer en europe
ça suffit ils apprennent des choses et
aussi c'est vrai pour les européens qui
essaie aussi de de travailler plus avec
le ballon parce que c'est une équilibre
de deux choses aujourd'hui
s'il n'a pas ça on va manquer notre coup
oui alors robert en a glissé un mot et
de l'une des nouveautés de cette coupe
du monde c était que les hommes en noir
les arbitres sont assistés désormais
c'est une pratique est courante dans les
sports majeurs en amérique du nord
mais pour la première fois en coupe du
monde on introduit donc cette assistance
vidéo
qu'est ce que vous en pensez des amis
alors allez-y paloma je crois que c'est
une bonne idée
j'ai coiffé il y à toute la question de
et on peut questionner les déçus si la
décision finale quant aux eaux aux
cartes jaunes français mais en tout cas
les cartons jaunes qui ont été
distribués et qui finalement montre
qu'une équipe et discipliné ou passer
dix exactement peut questionner
cependant la reprise vidéo peut donner
une perspective différente qu'on n'avait
pas auparavant et puis l'aide des
arbitres à l'intérieur de cette capsule
vidéo peut être je sais pas je trouve
que c'est complémentaire au travail des
arbitres
été annulée grâce à 7 cette année
le grand problème c'est peut-être eux
aussi qu'ils sont pas encore et savent
pas encore comment agir d'après ma parce
qu'il ya des des fautes que il appelle
il n'y a pas de fraude qu'ils appellent
pas je me souviens à géométrie variable
j c ils s'attendent tout le temps comme
vers les plus forts comme disait
l'entraîneur portugais de l'iran c'était
quand
quand c'est messi ronaldo la vidéo voit
autre chose
je me souviens de du match suisse celle
s'est levé s'est levé puis cédé pouvant
ta vie pouvant table reinhardtii sur
l'attaquant de celui qui était entre
deux gars ils l'ont embrassée et puis
rien même si les gars ont protesté
il n'a pas appelé au vidéo pourquoi
parce que tout simplement on s'est
aperçu j'ai pas tous les chiffres la
mairie on a utilisé 3 135 x 1 depuis le
premier tour le le le ce qui est
surréaliste là dedans c'est qu'on
s'aperçoit aussi que les grandes nations
sont favorisés alors on peut se demander
si la fifa s'est pas trouvé un super
jouer pour venir d'avoir une finale
serbie corée du sud je suis pas sûr
qu'il y aura beaucoup de monde qui
regardera ça et aussi a pas beaucoup de
monde n'y a pas d'argent
moi ce que je trouve dommage c'est que
le soccer c'est un mélange de tragédie
grecque et de commedia dell'arte et là
on est en train de tout donner au génie
artificielle on est en train d'enlever
l'émotion qui fait et l'émotion et
l'erreur
l'erreur on est en train d'enlever à
l'humain ce qui restait du vin dans le
soccer c'est à dire que va oui l'homme
en noir peut se tromper et et et le
joueur peut aussi jouer avec le fait
qu'il peut simuler par exemple a fait
une halte x et il y en a qui sont très
très forts comme artiste c'est dommage
qu'on enlève tout ça parce que c'est ça
aussi le soccer cc c'est une fête c'est
un jeu
c'est une pièce de théâtre mais c'est
surtout pas un truc là qu'on va mettre
dans un ordinateur
et puis qu'on va dire maintenant on
enlève tout ça on enlève l'émotion dans
la rame
la main de dieu de maradona s'il avait
eu à les regarder
c'est bien que vous disiez ça parce que
on entend encore on en parle encore
époque comme une tricherie
on en parle comme un geste mais qui il a
connu lui même et il a imploré dieu et
d'écouté dieu m'a dit de faire ça j'en
attends encore on reparle et c'est quand
même assez mais regardez on se souvient
même pas du résultat du match ont ce
soir qu'on se on se souvient de cet
événement là parce que parce que c'est
théâtral
c est on en train d'enlever justement
cette dimension humaine que le soccer en
train de leur entrée dans un carcan et
sa semelle mais peut-être que c'est un
peu trop tôt pour juger soi ses bons
mots vers où on verra la fin du mondial
ce que ça ressort mais il ya une chose
déjà qui est certain c'est que il ya une
recrudescence des penaltys alors là
c'est incroyable record c'est 24 depuis
que ça a commencé alors que le record
précédent c'était 18
donc là il ya quelque chose quand même
qui qui qui de nouveau sur les penalties
sur les arrêts de jeu comme ça donc sur
les fractures dans les matches et tout
ça donc il ya quelque chose qui va être
analysées à ce point de vue là parce que
24 penalty tu déjà c'est beaucoup et si
on disait par exemple qu'on en sort
cette pratique là du mondial pour la
généraliser dans les matchs
conventionnelle de championnat en tout
cas peu partout dans le monde est ce que
vous seriez pour bien vous vous seriez
pour
la réserve qu'on attend d'un petit peu
avant de dia les plus en plus en plus en
détail mais c'est parce qu'il ya
d'autres sports qui l'a qui la met en
pratique qui la met en pratique depuis
si longtemps que je n'aurais cru que y
avait quand même
on connaissait on connait lüthi
donc on peut s'en servir de la bonne
manière mais ce que j'entends c'est que
ça continue des termites faire même s'il
y a un écran qui lui aussi qui nous
montrent la réalité
donc oui au tennis quand on utilise par
exemple la reprise vidéo bas le joueur
s'y perd sa cause
on va lui enlever quelque chose tandis
que là tu as juste à lever le doigt
et si tu t'appelles ronaldo messi je
m'excuse de bertheaume
mais on va dire on va l'écouter parce
que c'est une star neymar pareil écoute
moi j'ai vu des incongruités et ça tue
le jeu ça tue le jeu c'est ça en plus et
ayant une autre chose quant à moi
peut-être on va être nostalgique on
moment donné mais le soccer c'est
universel je vois pas comment un match
en afrique en amérique du sud et pays
plus pauvres comment ils ont eux ils
vont avoir le moyen d'installer des
vidéos en enfer dès maintenant et ça ça
fait que les riches vont avoir lé
peuvent pas de vidéo
c'est pour ça que le soccer était très
beau c'est parce qu'elle était égale
partout en grand petit c'est sûr il ya
eu des erreurs et à des influences il ya
des des équipes que qui ont plus de
pouvoir et ça ça joue et qu'il faut
regarder c'est de ce côté là parce que
quand à moi ça devait être peut-être
j'étudie les verts le but la ligne de
but quand ce vallon rendre entre par
l'ajax est moins mauvais mais arrêtez
ces cinquante mille 80000 personnes qui
sont là bas accusés
qu'est ce qu'il va décider il tout le
monde attend 2 3 minutes 4 minutes
ce que tu sais même plus qui a here
parce qu'avant tu avais fais tu savais
que c'était lui quel talent ailleurs
parce qu'il allait prendre la mauvaise
décision par rapport à ton équipe
maintenant là tu sais même plus qui se
cache dans une banane on alors non là
mais tu sais pas si c'est lui qui a pris
la décision si celle arbitres de champ
qu'après la décision
si c'est les quatre arbitres qui
regardaient les vidéos et tout donner
laissez nous encore eaux des salles
c'est ça c'est le nom de l' arbitre qui
est mais qui a puni l'argentine a là un
final qui n'était pas notre idée pas
penalty mais ça reste dans l'histoire ou
tandis qu'aujourd'hui là tu sais même
ouvert du 1er mai au pour cette baisse
mais il faut penser que quoi faire des
seuils justice y avait quand même
beaucoup d'injustices parfois parfois la
serbie prenait des décisions très
injuste puis oui on avait quitté hier
mais en même temps on était complètement
dépourvu d'options donc là il ya il a
décidé ça puis il est tout seul à
prendre cette décision
donc l'effet d'avoir des gens qui sont
dans une salle vide qui observe c'est
quand même ça donne quand même une autre
perspective
on parlera aux marocains la passion des
fédérations et envoyé une lettre en
traîneau parce que parce
qu'effectivement le maroc a perdu a
perdu sur des des décisions de vidéos
alors qu'il devrait être dans le tour
suivant en tout cas dans un autre
mondial il aurait été dans st
absolument parlant justement de
controverses bon la seule équipe
africaine qu'avec mes chances réalistes
de se retrouver au second tour le
sénégal a perdu parce que il avait plus
de cartons jaunes que le japon alors il
voulait par exemple et il faut nous il
partagé oui ils ont mal un moment donné
il faut départager
quand on allait l'égalité pure on va où
et je pense que c'est quand même un beau
message aussi de dire qu'on va aller
vers le fair play on va regarder qui a
fait le moins d'erreurs qui a été le
plus le plus acceptable dans le jeu qui
est je veux dire c'est important aussi
comme message de dire qu'on va passer
par le fair play pour voir quelle équipe
passe au second tour c'est un beau
message en tout cas c'est mieux que
et toutes ces années ils n'ont pas de
logique
c'est vrai que c'est bien de d'amener le
fair-play là dedans mais pas dans une
décision aussi importante mois selon moi
c'est balle au pied que tu gagnes ou tu
perds alors ce qu'on pourrait faire
c'est c'est carrément de prendre les
deux équipes qui sont parce que y'en a
pas quinze des équipes qui sont dans
cette situation là de prendre les deux
équipes font les réunit il ya la journée
de repos le vendredi on y va aux tirs au
but c'est tout et puis et puis au moins
tu diras ben j'ai été exclu mais j'ai
raté mon penalty rouge où j'ai réussi à
passer en huitièmes mais au moins c'est
un ballon rond à l'époque j'ai regardé
dans le passé on tirait au sort c'est
encore pire
non mais il ya des via des équipes ont
été qualifiées au tirage au sort tu
imagines tu te prépares quatre ans pour
ça et puis c'est comme ça mais non mais
non c'est une belle aux pieds moi je
pense que ça se gagne ou suspecte oui
énormément
je suis pas d'accord avec robert parce
que ça pouvait avoir trois équipes la
même cité dans une situation et on
pouvait pas faire appeler les trois
équipes bon toi avait que lui lui avec
lui non moi j'y serai plus vers l'équipe
qui attaque le plus et ça se voit le
corps les le corner oui ça forcerait une
équipe à s'ouvrir de plus parce qu'elles
savaient que s'ils avaient l'égalité à
la fin bon le terroir voire 8
que dans le corner est un indicateur
exact de l'impact d'une équipe pour
passer au tour suivant
mais j'accepte la discipline aussi parce
qu'il ya des équipes qui font du théâtre
1 6 dans les théâtres de sur le terreau
est ici notre équipe elle a été bien ne
pas pourquoi ils tombent tout le temps
moi je tourne fox oui j'accepte
j'accepte ya des gens qui te rend plus
facilement que d'autres et si vous avez
l'air plus gros par rapport à ce qui
semble à priori vous être fautifs pour
qu'ils avaient l'air plus fort plus
musclé mais mais vous savez ce que je
dis c'est qu'il ya des joueurs comme
comme neiman x et total de bons joueurs
très forts mais la moitié c'est lui qui
se trouvait tout ça parce que ronaldo ne
fait pas lui nommé non j'ai vu des
choses quand même qu'ils peuvent au
niveau du fair-play là j'avais lu dans
un journal que bon évidemment le japon
gagnait parce que on peut rentrer dans
des clichés facilement au sens que
compte le sénégal les japonais sont plus
disciplinés on peut il ya des
sous-entendus défaut il faut faire
attention sur quelle équipe est plus
discipliné une autre parce qu'elle vient
de l'oeil de la perception qu'ont à
l'aja de leicester youtube com voilà si
les arbitres sont pas tous prêts à ce
type de jeu on parlait de différents
saint marc berthod parlait de l'asie de
culturellement on apporte quelque chose
c'est sûr qu' il y ait des endroits et
c'est papa laumac va me contredire
on est plus fougueuse way
en amérique latine et puis on est plus
technique et plus je dirais décontractée
dans le football africain par exemple il
ya peut-être des arbitres eux qui ne
sont pas habitués à ce type de chose et
qu'ils vont mettre un carton jaune alors
que dans leur championnat respectif bien
c'est normal
combien de fois on a même vu les anglais
qui sont quand même des champions du
fair play
des fois va dire ben je comprends pas
parce que nous là dans notre football
anglais basse sru dont on se cogne là
dessus
c'est comme le nombre de fois que j'ai
vu les arbitres de cette coupe du monde
intervenir avant un coup franc ou avant
un corner parce que ça ça se sache
chamaillent dans le dans la surface de
réparation mais ça tout le temps était
comme ça on dirait qu'ils écoutent la
senteur c'est aussi ça d'accrocher des
maillots je sais que je vais mourir
si on regarde le nombre de commotions
cérébrales dans l'air ce que l'on peut
voir que ça toujours été un peu comme ça
on dépose pensées ont su wei 7 jan mayen
peut on lui de l'héritage je pense
qu'une solution mais qui je suis pour
redonner de d opinion mais moi ça c'est
que les arbitres ils fassent le tour du
monde ça veut dire que des arbitres
asiatique il devait au moment donné
arbitres et a négocié le contrat pour
qu'ils y ont accès c'est exactement
exactement qui le font beaucoup parler
des arbitres je dois l'extérieur c'est
une c'est une solution on avait même un
arbitre de la mls à coupe du monde ne
faut pas rire l'a22 bas qu'ils
apprennent d'abord arbitrer dans leur
championnat
on les envoie la sévère 2 2 une des deux
a déjà invité de marque
ouais ça veut dire que c'est pas tout
tous les habitants européenne
sud-américaine a été victime des
mauvaises
de toute façon la décision avait été
prise déjà enfin la règle et éthique ses
rangs avant le mondial donc on savait
pas quoi s'en tenir
mais ce que je pense quelqu'un a dû tout
à l'heure c'est que au niveau de la
perception savez les sénégalaises comme
les camerounais c'est des gens qui sont
assez robustes sur le terrain donc la
perception du du jeu brutal est très
facile à avoir surtout s'ils ont en face
d'eux des gens plus petit alors c'est
très facile de penser que le plus gros a
été plus dur alors le plus gros plus il
a juste mis son pied mais bon ya cette
perception qui est là et comme on a dit
tout à l'heure parfois le fait de ne pas
savoir comment ça se passe ailleurs
induire ce genre de maintenant la coupe
du monde on le dit souvent c'est une
grande fête c'est sa grand messe
mondiale de ce sport
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
cette coupe du monde en russie a le même
effet que les coupes habituel c'est à
dire qu' il ya des peines espèce de 2,2
de fièvre s'est emparée de la planète en
planète foot ou encore en russie même
d'après ce que vous osez la télévision
est ce que vous avez l'impression que
cette coupe du monde là c'est un grand
moment de sport comme habituellement
robert maman je pense que oui d'abord
les stades sont pleins
l'ambiance à l'air d'être là et puis il
ya du monde on s'attendait à quelque
chose de beaucoup plus froid un peu
comme ce que j'ai vécu aux jeux
olympiques à sotchi mais mais là non on
est un même c'est même si d'habitude les
russes sont pas cette exubérance
latino-américaine que j'ai vécu au entre
autres au brésil mais non je pense que
la fête est là je prends et j'ai été
agréablement surpris que stade était
plein un petit peu moins au début la
mémé mais même quand le panama jouer
il y avait du monde et puis avait de
l'ambiance ç'a pris du temps pour qu'on
sait danser rend compte que la coupe
s'en venait seulement les mordus le
savent et puis des prêts ils y avaient
fait leur calendrier en conséquence mais
sinon ça a pris du temps mais une fois
qu'elle ça commence et je crois que tout
le monde était prêt puis 45 mille
mexicains à moscou c'est juste un
exemple de la fièvre que ça crée à
chaque fois ismaël les coupes du monde
sont maintenant à géopolitique on a
toujours des a priori piquant quand
c'était en russie on s'est dit bon
[ __ ] poutine et tout ce qui se passe
est ce que les gens vont pouvoir y aller
est-ce que ça l'ambiance comment elle va
être est ce que c'est une nation de
sports de soccer on se rend compte que
oui ben oui des bleus comme disait dans
les stades sont pleins les gens sont
voyager les gens sont là bas les
péruviens sont aussi une délégation
énorme la bosse et l'incroyable donc les
les portes ont été ouverts donc ça
montre aussi une image peut-être aussi
c'est la volonté de la russie qui veut
que sais-je auzonnet peut passer jeux
olympiques excusez moi mais c'est cette
coupe du monde la soit une vitrine et
qu'elle montre aussi que c'est un pays
ouvert
avec tout ce qui se passe aujourd'hui je
pense que pour poutine et moscou cette
importance ils sont courageux parce que
les conditions étaient quand même assez
restrictive
il faut que dans une ville tu te déclare
chaque fois que tu vas dans une ville
donc si tu si tu suis ton équipe à
chaque fois faut que tu te déclare à la
police ou alors il ya des services de
sécurité dans les hôtels qui vont
enregistrer et c'est donc c'est quand
même assez strict et j'ai été étonné moi
effectivement de voir autant de
délégations les sénégalais hier c'était
extraordinaire ils ont fait un spectacle
dans l'est dans les tribunes c'est
dommage qu'ils soient plus là parce
qu'on n'aura plus le spectacle quoique
ils vont peut-être se trouver une équipe
à soutenir le brésil soit les africains
niveau des assistances du pauvre au
début parce que j'ai quand même vu deux
matches qui avait beaucoup de place de
vite surtout à 2 propose deux choses la
première c'est que depuis que les états
unis son championnat du monde ce qui
amène les plus de touristes au pays qui
organise le soccer et comme les états
unis n'étaient pas qualifiés nous grande
partie de des spectateurs et ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas la danse avec
appréhension
oui au début et puis le même la russie
ils sont là mais je pense qu'ils sont
pas un pays de sault caire comme la
phrase comme l'angleterre comme vitalic
et de ces deux choses là ça m'a fait
peur parce que quand il ya le
championnat du monde on veut voir céder
deux bons matches et des démâté des
stades remplis parce que c'est ça qui
fait qu'ils donnent les land art oui
mais je suis pas sûr que la russie ne
soit pas fait ce que je pense que et
peut-être que au niveau des équipes ou
des championnats mais les gens aiment le
socceroo si oui c'est quelque chose et
je lui fis je me fie aux championnats
qu'ils organisent
il ya dix mille spectateurs oui mille
spectateurs
ils sont peut-être le 10ème 11ème au
niveau des assistances au niveau
international au niveau du championnat
et c'est un pays qu look est pour
beaucoup mais individuellement ils ont
quand même des joueurs de talent qui
quelques-uns d'ailleurs qui sont dans
les championnats européens où absolument
alors on se dirige tranquillement vers
les huitièmes de finale avant d'avoir
vos vous choix là on sait que la grosse
suprise tout le monde s'entend sur la
table à dessus c'est l'élimination
précoce de l'allemagne est ce que vous
voyez une autre grande pays a besoin
d'une grande nation notre grande équipe
suivre les traces de l'allemagne bien
sûr évidemment beaucoup ok je crois que
l'argentine est blessé et je pense
qu'avec le premier match avec la
dernière victoire
je pense qu'ils vont revenir ah oui donc
laissé blessés l'itep a laissé de
grandes équipes comme grande nation qui
pourrait éventuellement sur keep
répartir de façon très inattendue de
façon précoce de ces le plaisir à face à
face au mexique
[Rires]
je penserai plus à l'espagne - qui qui
m'a pas vraiment pas impressionné depuis
le début de la compétition les deux
grosses équipes gèrent l espagne et la
france là sans hésiter et et quelques
petites équipes on n'attend pas du tout
voyez vous faire l'uruguay oui oui c'est
vrai le russe et sa mêlée
traditionnellement c'est ça le rugby
mais dès demain il va éliminer le
portugal de faire sauf s'ils arrivent à
faire douter on a le dos parce que si
ronaldo arrive à douter
y'a plus rien pour le porte feuille j'ai
peu d'espoir mais le japon j'aimerais
soc que le japon oui une première
quelque chose qui change de le japon
pourquoi pas ce qu'on a des loutres fois
c'est que on voulait avoir une équipe
africaine asiatique pour faire
changement un peu oui
alors donc on y va tout de suite le
premier match argentine france alors là
je vais parce que lors de la dernière
émission va être confronté à noah nos
pronostics donc cette fois ci on va les
prendre en note alors ismaël france
argentine qui l'emportent
la france la france pour ismaël robert
l'argentine sans aucune excitation
justement parce que messi s'est
réveillée avec son but magnifique
lors du dernier match et la france j'ai
l'impression qu'elle est en train de
vivre son syndrome de 2010 j'ai pas
l'impression qu'il ya une cohésion à
l'intérieur du vestiaire j'ai pas une
cohésion aussi avec le l'entraîneur qui
a ses petits chouchous dans l'équipe et
c'est est-ce que soudainement il va y
avoir le réveil de gorik de griezmann
j'espère parce qu'il n'a rien fait
depuis le début de la coupe du monde et
mba p il pense qu'il est devenu ronaldo
et messi à lui tout seul
donc je suis pas sûr que ça fasse une
équipe super solide on verra peut-être
qu'ils vont nous étonner mais
s'ils jouent comme ils ont joué contrôle
danemark les argentins ils vont manger
les coqs gaulois mais n'apportera parle
2010 2016 en jouant à la maison ils ont
perdu le championnat
alors justement n'a rien trouvé qui dans
cette maladie si je vois l'argentine
malgré un fait c'est vrai je me demande
pourquoi messi s'est réveillée comme ça
soudainement sans rien faire d'autre les
autres matchs mais là je crois qui
réveillé puis on dit que quand messi bat
tout va en argentine ils ont dieu le
pape ait mis si j'en ai trilogie
le pape qui veille sur les gradins et
parfois qui s'endort aussi dans le dieu
plutôt c'est dieu dieu maradona alors
maintenant urbain portugal
on sait déjà pour qu'une heure berthod
le portail varane est d'accord alors
norbert tous le portugal mon coeur me
dit lowey mais je crois que le portugal
va l'emporter
c'est un voisin qui l'influencent c'est
vraiment moi je crois que j'aimerais que
j'aimerais que l'uruguay gagne parce que
je crois qu'il le mérite
ils sont beaux jeux donc mais je crois
que la qualité de l'équipe pour tou-te-s
est supérieur mais j'ai l'impression que
le portugal va pécher par excès de
confiance on arrive dans le moment où il
faut qu'ils montrent que et ils l'ont
montré aux championnats d'europe
notamment
mais il faut qu'il montre que c'est une
grande nation mais ils ont en face des
uruguayens qui ne vont jamais arrêté et
c'est là ces supplices c'est le supplice
de maringouins les uruguayens nous ont
montré d'ailleurs en gagnant leurs trois
mâts bah oui ah oui j'entends très
convaincante et pas avec des équipes de
seconde zone
et effectivement ils sont là pour pour
continuer je donnerai un petit coup de
coeur pour le régler dans des places à
la banque robert c l'uruguay maintenant
mon cher s'annonce en tout cas un match
formidable et qu'on le souhaite parce
que vraiment nous à une confrontation
que kiki qui s'annonce mais portugal
s'ils continuent à jouer comme ils ont
joué là depuis le début pas de raison
qu'ils perdent
ismaël dis donc le portugal espagne
russie bon là je penserai plus facile
parce que la russie c'est une socket qui
est tout est prévu il n'y a pas de
création mais les bus des tec russe tout
les bucs ont fait pas mal c'est des
petites équipes
j'ai rien contre l'art avec sérieux et
et as tu vu comment ils ont été ramenés
alors la suite dès qu'ils ont eu peu de
notre niveau
donc tu vois ces sites et l'espagne
effectivement
l'espagne va perdre mais pas durant ce
match
ok donc pour l'instant cette unanimité
l'espagne face à la russie ok parfait
alors croatie danemark bat la croatie
évidemment elle aussi gagné tous ses
matches qui a humilié l'argentine 3 0
c'est vraiment la belle révélation avec
des avec un soccer solide intelligent
costaud et non les croates qu'ils vont
manger le danemark ont créé t
qui était bien mais je pense qu'ils sont
à la limite de leurs moyens
ouais c'est pas les dames acajou et
comme la france est insupportable oui on
va pas pour la croatie
l'oedème juste pour les punir de ce
match soporifique
alors il faut qu'ils s'en sortent comme
moi j'aimerais que ce soit croatie mais
attention attention que les danois ils
sont grands physiciens
ils ferment tous les espaces il peut
faire une contre attaque peut-être une
couette en corner la menteuse
ils sont grands mais c'est un but de
féret ça peut être difficile
vous allez pour la croatie en sachant
que c'est surtout que je penche pour la
croatie oui mais j'ai quand même des
réticences sont d'accord vous êtes un
camp croate réticents et tout à fait moi
je suis tout à fait d'accord
la croatie mais est le danemark pour
faire très très attention
ils nous ont prouvé qu'ils pouvaient
nous surprendre à chaque fois ils l'ont
fait donc ils peuvent le refaire
voilà alors le match important pour
notre ami
paloma brésil mexique ils voulaient
gagner ils voulaient gagner justement
est en premier lieu dès le groupe pour
pour vous peut pas jouer contre le
brésil
donc là c'est ce que je prends tout les
mecs et c'est possible ils sont gagnés
quand l'allemagne
ok pourquoi pas c'est le brésil ça va
être facile
je n'aimerais pas parce que c'est quand
même une équipe de la concacaf et moi
j'évite dans la concacaf et j'aimerais
que les équipes de concacaf as bien mais
malheureusement je pense que les
mexicains ils vont s'énerver
ont sauvé par sauver est difficile je
vois du brésil temps sur eux et puis non
plus il ya plusieurs joueurs bons dans
l'équipe mexicaine pic quelqu'un dans
l'équipe brésilienne dans l'équipe reste
de l'équipe du mexique hommes sur votre
pas la crise il est alors robert vous
avait prédit dès le départ que dans un
bain brésil donc c'est pas maintenant
que vous allez changer non changeraient
pas et je vais me dire pourquoi parce
que je trouve que lors de leur dernier
match on a retrouvé le football samba
ce football magique que qui date des
années pelé où tout était facile où
toutes les passes étaient faciles où il
y avait de l'intelligence dans le jeu
ils variété aussi dans le jeu ont tout
n'était pris activité c'est neymar a su
même s'effacer lui qui d'habitude
suspens position de buteur à chaque fois
c'est lui qui était l'instigateur de de
toutes sortes de d'ouverture de passe
etc
j'espère que le marcelo qui s'est blessé
et s'est remis un petit peu et tout mais
on a vu des choses que même sans lui qui
est un chef d'orchestre phénoménal non
jeu on a retrouvé cette magie j'espère
qu'ils vont la garder jusqu'à la fin
c'est vrai que le brésil des grandes
années et là franchement moi je pense
que c'est bien parti mais mais de toute
façon que ce soit maintenant que ça
arrive parce que les autres il faut
éliminer par belgique japon je pense là
aussi la limite et dansé autour de vous
parce que les japonais sait les
samouraïs
c'est des kamikazes et puis là c'est pas
péjoratif ce que je dis ça veut dire
qu'ils sont en mission et ils ont trois
poumons par joueur comme les coréens
je n'ai jamais vu une équipe qui fait un
football total comme celui là ça me
rappelle l'ajax amsterdam ddd des
grandes années de crise où tout le monde
attaque tout le monde défend on court
tout le temps et et cd peste parce que
il te cola et à chaque fois quelques que
leurs adversaires ont le ballon ils ont
un deux japonais et ils font la
différence dans les dents les grandeurs
j'ai été impressionné qu'il n'y ait pas
plus de but de la tête contre le japon
est lent il sont là parce qu'ils collent
il accroche mais il accroche proprement
et ils sont surprenants
moi je la belgique qui est le une des
pour moi des finalistes de cette coupe
du monde va devoir se méfier et nous
offrir le même jeu qui nous en faire
jusqu'à maintenant c'est à dire un jeu
n'importe qui peut marquer dans cette
équipe là c'est vraiment magnifique de
les voir jouer les diables rouges
d'accord vous allez pour les diables
rouges malgré tout robert et j'ai pris
un pot de la belge est parce que je
crois que la belgique avec son
historique de sa force d'essence être ça
va ça va avancer mais j'aime et je me
voir les japonais avancé moi j'suis
d'accord les japonais faut vraiment
faire très attention la belgique a du
souci à se faire si vraiment ça passe ou
ça casse avec ce match là s'ils arrivent
à passer ça peut être les champions pour
moi mais franchement faut passer le
japon ma tête avec la belgique mais mon
corps le japon oui c'est donc j'ai dit
dès le début que j'aimerais qu'une
équipe à l'extérieur de l'europe
argentine plaisir d'une équipe qui
calera ruisseau l'océanie l'asie elle
elle mais au final vous met la belgique
va gagner suisses anglais de nos fils
suède suisse suède ça ne regardez pas
tout sauf la suède parce que j'ai jamais
vu non mais non mais vous êtes vous
allez vous promener dans la petite tu
aimes tu as l'impression à séisme à des
arts j'ai jamais vu la petite italie
pendant une coupe du monde aussi et
c'est dommage justement cash de
l'acompte l'action chaleur au niveau de
l'engouement
c'est une des choses qui nous fera parce
qu'en italie là on a l'impression que
mes sur demande et ils font partie du
succès d'une continuation et c'est vrai
qu'il manque un petit côté de ça un
petit peu quand il manque quelque chose
dans un plat tu te dis c'est une scène
live ou l'huile d'olive
bah là il manque 1000 d'olive l'axé
excuse moi et les suisses la attend la
nati là et l'équipe
ils ont des supers joueurs en tout cas
moi je vais donner pour le carré pour la
raison un but superbe et où il n'était
pas assez bon pour ses skis moqueur à
l'impact parce que au milieu de terrai
lui il faisait des bulles
il marque et je pense que la marque et 8
au 10 bus pendant la saison je suppose
que les joueurs qui sont là il ajouté qu
il n'y a pas d'ouverture
c'est ça qui manque à la pac man mais il
a un jour pour la suisse la suisse que
je pense que devait être illuminé parce
que je pense que ça la serbie devait
être là en tout à cause de deux penaltys
qu que génèrent les tantôt et moi
c'était
moi ce qui va être très équilibré mais
peut-être la suisse va gagner ok alors
donc norberto va penche pour la suisse
mais difficile à les pâtes à les
départager parce que pour moi la suisse
la suède c'est un peu l'heure du style
de jeu c'est difficile de jouer sont
forts aussi les suédois un peu plus oui
mais les suisses ont way we met un peu
plus de vitesse chez les suisses dont
qui compense un peu avec ça mais dans la
suisse par par parker mais la suède
pourquoi pas aussi je veux dire les
aurait pas de la petite italie va de
toute façon la suisse on peut tout bas
ils ont tout le monde ils ont les
allemands ils ont eu à l'iso la france
des joueurs d'un peu partout
c'est un ensemble c'est peut-être le mas
la suisse aussi pour la soirée
en fait je prends pas pour eux oui j'y
crois qu'il est d'accord ok alors
dernier dernières confrontations
colombie allemagne angleterre je veux
dire comment bien que le terme oui bah
ça va pas être facile parce que c'est la
colombie qui va gagner
ouais moi c'est marrant je pense
exactement la même chose qu'ils écoutent
ils ont un jeu eux aussi qui eux aussi
sont réveillés s'ils arrivent à faire
attention à un week-end ouais je pense
qu'ils vont gagner
norbert les parce que c'est une affaire
qui est qui qui bouge beaucoup qui
rapide qui qui qui qui a la tête au jeu
cliquez vente
le jeu est toujours les peas ont
l'impression que les anglais ils ont un
coach en tout cas est ce que c'était ce
qui s'est passé au dernier match contre
la belgique qui me fait dire ça mais
capot pris les bonnes décisions
il a vraiment pas pris les bonnes
décisions parce que ils ont joué à
savoir qui est laide deuxième puis les
belges avant de les ebook août on joue
plus on joue et ils nous ont montré du
beau jeu mais ils ont ils à faire entrer
kane à la toute fin c'est pas pour le
protéger en plus non il a pris les
visions bizarre d'ailleurs je lisais les
journaux aujourd'hui et ils sont pas
contents l'angleterre du choix qu'a fait
qui a fait le sélectionneur anglais en
tout cas on verra bien ce que je prends
pour la colombie cependant je crois qu
ils ont eu un peu de difficulté dans le
premier match a très bien joué au
dernier parce qu'il fallait vraiment
qu'ils jouent bien mais ils sont vu la
difficulté les colombiens moi je prends
pour eux c'est sûr mais elles disent qu
on constate un réveil de la colombie
effectivement la colombie est présente
moi je je je
ouais la colombie je pense qu'ils vont
gagner nager avec des douches c'est quoi
si je gagne à un prix là je pourrai plus
alors allons-y pour la colombie ont
battu la colombie
alors puisque notre dernière rencontre
aura lieu après la finale la semaine
après la finale
alors allons-y tout de suite alors
pourquoi pas je t'en serai pas là en
plus voilà donc ma présence à signifie
qu'au fond on va là-bas non non non on
va confirmer s'il est content on était
avec robert et alain robert dont vous
confirmez votre choix de du champion et
j'hésite parce que moi j'ai refait mes
calculs milliard dans le tableau et je
me dis que
la belgique pourrait très bien se
retrouver finaliste victorieuse de cette
coupe du monde
ok alors donc la belgique pour robert
norberto mais c'est sûr que j'aimerais
que ce soit le portugal mais j'ai des
doutes quand même même si le portugal si
on regarde le championnat d'europe ils
ont pas gagné de match 90 minutes et ils
ont regagné la côte ça peut difficile
mais à pezens petit le fils qu'il va y
louer la clé peut-être c'est le brésil
de l'équipe que qui a plus de chances si
le mexique ne l'éliminé pas si je suis
constant avec tout ce que j'ai dit
depuis le départ depuis le début
évidemment le brésil le brésil
alors les amis donc merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir de vous être prêté au jeu comme
je dis on va se retrouver le 20 juillet
donc ce sera après la finale et c'est
tout ce que tout se passe bien on va
pouvoir confronter vos pronostics à ce
que ça va passer
robin ne sera pas là mais en tout cas on
va veiller à ce que sa voix soit
entendue par le man et paloma norberto
robert ismaël merci infiniment d'être
venu